hey everybody what's going on blay here
and i'm here with the great eric
hutchinson eric how's it going let's get
some clapping yeah yeah
awesome and uh we are backstage here at
the chicago theater during our week of
shows in chicago so we have a couple of
questions for you are you ready
yeah all right perfect he's like no
interview's over immediately do you have
any pre-show rituals that you do any any
superstitions perhaps um i'm not gonna
do it tonight but usually we will cut
the head of one goat off just oh
fantastic fantastic perfect it's an old
santeria thing that my family always did
uh what do you like to do to pass the
time besides fiddler on the old guitar
um i love eating really yeah are you big
no wait are you when you say you like
eating are you a foodie or you just love
shoving stuff in your mouth i'm both
i mean i don't like the term foodie for
some reason it to me has like uh
i don't know
negative connotations we're in chicago
which is like the land of
food food yes what are you got any
chicago favorites yeah well i mean last
time i was here right at this place
called avec what is a vec what is that
uh it's just simple clean
like you're always such a foodie you've
always said about food but every food is
or it's chilly yeah it's just simply
cleaner it's chilly it's real real
flavor honest cooking you know a little
bit of spice yeah exactly i love using
your music to party too or to get into a
good time by myself i just drink cologne
in my apartment with is that too weird
to say no it's actually the number one
way people listen to the music it's
fantastic drowning their tears fantastic
yes
um what kind of music do you listen to
like when you're cooking like what what
do you put on i love i love all kinds of
stuff like slayer slayer acoustic slayer
slayer
unplugged album it's yeah really
terrible
um now i love like paul simon and the
beatles and stevie wonder and uh i love
a lot of like big band stuff you know
sinatra and louis prima stuff like that
um and is there anybody who you would
want to
uh collaborate with who you haven't who
you haven't i mean i would love to work
with kanye if if boney bear can do it
why why not right watch the throne too
with eric johnson that sounds great yeah
like sales
sales exactly more of an art project
foodies in paris maybe that could be
what it's called
here's a good question
i'll be the judge of that
oh
this interview's taking a turn for the
better you're on tour a lot you're in in
town uh
for one night best place to pick up the
best place to pick up
which is plotlist
i mean i don't know what it's called i
just learned this time i didn't know
what it meant i saw like a picture in a
truck stop who does that whose dream gig
is that you know
you know i'm trying to land as the
trucker
i'm not sure it's a dream gig i think
it's like a couple you after you've hit
your roadie prime or your groupie prime
you know you're just just the same way
musicians you know lower down the ranks
you see that girl who's doing the
groupie stuff oh man
now you're a lot lizard 50 years later
just lot leisure it's as you at the way
back down or you start with the lot
lizards and work your way up exactly you
know what i'm saying you get it all
that's because they're probably not that
intimidating because they would all they
wanted it's like some meth or basketball
or something
it's the same thing it's the arc same as
musicians a lot of times when we play
venues right and we sell them out the
owners will say to me afterwards but
we'll see on the way down is that true
yeah oh my god what dicks what giant
dicks and that's when you little shot of
realism yeah you stab and you just
immediately that's why i carry the shank
we were talking about off camera it's
true off camera we're at a good
off-camera shank conversation i think
you step on the foot and then slice and
then you push
i don't know
there's something and then a step which
distracts them and then a blow to the
face i think this would distract them
just to the throat yeah that would be
distracting again and then you got a
murder on your hands
but then you're on tour so then you just
leave immediately and you're fine of
course then they could probably trace if
you if the murders were happening
exactly on your tour room was this your
original question how do you get rid of
a body when you're on tour yes that was
my original question got it i need help